the start goes to the 28 year old
right-hander acquired in november in the
robert stephenson trade from the rockies
jeff hoffman
we've seen it jeff hoffman's gonna have
to establish once again
just like tyler molly yesterday that
fastball
locate the fastball he's got a big
curveball he spent his entire career
with the rockies
2-2
up and in
three-two pitch
arenado hits it out to left and extra
bases one hop off the wall and left
and a two-out stand-up double for nolan
orenado
hits everything hard doesn't he yeah of
course he does well you think about that
too you see the pitch before a fastball
up at his eyes in off the plate really
throws him off here and then you get
this change up down at the bottom of the
zone that he just stays right on it's a
two-ball two-strike count hoffman trying
to work around the two out double brings
it home swinging a foul tip stevenson
holds on to strike three once again the
split from huffman
and he has his first strike out of the
game carlos martinez last season five
starts one of those was against the reds
went four innings gave up six hits a
couple of walks struck out eight the 2-2
pitch for joy vado swing and a mess
struck him out with a change up
one two three go the reds
i think the crowd can tell you who's at
the plate
multiple strides should retreat in the
outfield grass
swing and a miss
there's that breaking ball right there
start up at eye level
nice little bender
chopped
to short
one foot of throw up the line stays on
the bag and he's out
nice job by vato on the stretch
now for his teammate suarez with a
challenging toss
cardinals hold an option on carlos
martinez on his contract after the
season so personally a big year for him
fly ball into shallow center and the
catch made by the cardinals shortstop
paul deyoung justin williams from a
hitter's perspective you try to pick up
the ball as early as possible
nice elevated fastball right there but
jeff hoffman
cardinals have the lone hit of the ball
game that was a double off the left
field wall by nolan arenado
2-2 tough play for hoffman
sets his feet snap throw in time
athlete you know one thing in pfp and
spring training really work hard
on pitchers fielding practice
and you can see the follow through
setting the feet
something we talked about bunting the
other day from a pitcher
perspective trying to get the bunt down
well fielding your position is another
very important part of it as well so far
so good for carlos today though he looks
looks uh in control of himself he's
pounding the strike zone jonathan india
ground ball arenado to his left spinning
and makes the play
i know this comp has been made many a
time dan but it just reminds me when i
was fortunate enough to be pitching i'd
throw a sinker down in the way and i
didn't have to look cause scott roland
was gonna be right there at third base
one and two the count on tyler stevenson
swing and a miss strikeout number two
for carlos martinez
only one ball has left the infield
and he waves at it strikeout number
three nine up nine down to start this
afternoon for carlos martinez
while goldschmidt standing in the 2-2
strike three called fastball and a good
one over the inside corner from hoffman
and he just locked up paul goldschmidt
for his fourth strike out of the day oh
two
swinging a miss
jeff hoffman is fired up
he roars off the hill astiano's grounded
to short his first time up
oh first pitch
center field carlson
loses the ball castellano still on his
sprint he rips through second he's gonna
claim three
[Applause]
a stand-up triple for nick castellanos
bye-bye perfecto
you can see a slider right there left
over the middle of the plate and
cassiano does not miss it
at all and
hit that ball well off the center field
wall
hustling into third base first hit of
the game was perfect until that at bat
infield in joey bottom that's going to
be ripped to right
[Applause]
scores and joey votto delivers
first the perfect game
now the shutout one nothing reds this is
where yachty can be so good at taking
the ball the other way either productive
out or
drive them in
molina
base hit
oh neil will score
and we're tied 1-1
on the rbi
from iata molina
and the fans let him hear about it
double the single of
start of this cardinal fifth ground ball
could be two india gloves flips to
second one suarez the first double play
four six three
that is big
that gives a
pitcher a bit of a sigh of relief here's
the one-two pitch and a swing and a miss
struck him out
breaking ball down and out of the zone
sixth strikeout for jeff hoffman naquin
top of the lineup for the cincinnati
reds
ground ball diving play by edmond oh
what a play
takes a hit away and a run off the board
for the reds
tommy edmond a dazzling play at second
base
you're going to see this play a few
times this evening
second and third for nick castellanos
pull shift on hitters 2-1 club
center field
carlson retreating slows warning track
gone
nick castellanos has delivered
he's delivered drama he's delivered
leadership
he's delivered runs and he's delivered
the reds a 4-1 lead two on with one out
and a golden opportunity here to add to
that lead
grounded right side that's going to get
through base hit
the windmill is on they'll test williams
his throw to third
suarez scores senzel to third base the
red sparrow delivers it's 5-1
man at the corners arenado edges in at
third gets past molina sends out to the
play
save
india up to second 6-1
big time hitters count now
up the middle off the club of de young
india around third and the reds do it
again it's 7-1
score to base it gives stevenson
a ribby so the reds have runners at
first and second still only one out in
the inning
catches this ball and crushes hello sir
tyler naquin
thunder to right
a 10-1
blandino batting in the ninth position
that is smoked into the gap that's going
to be extra bases
mustaches scores stevenson around third
he scores make it a clean dozen 12-1
reds
and the reds are pitch away
aquino
ball game reds
series
reds